once upon a time in Romania there were a
thousand and one jump-scares that's one
way to describe the nun the fifth entry
in the conjuring horror film series
based on the Case Files of paranormal
investigators ed and Lorraine Warren the
nun is chronologically the first chapter
of the conjuring story taking audiences
back to 1952
for a few nights of religious horror the
nun is about more than just a Marilyn
Manson look-alike terrorizing Tikrit the
church in fact the movie weaves a web of
connections to every conjuring universe
movie that came before it if you were
too spooked by the final showdown to pay
that much attention to the what and the
why then relax we're ready to break down
what it all meant pop on your habits and
your purple stoles and let's dive into
the ending to the nun the foreshadowing
something is off about the abbey of st.
Cardus when the protagonist first
arrived father Burke and the novice
sister Irene are there investigating the
death of a nun suspected of taking her
own life their inquiry is aided by a
French Canadian expat named Maurice aka
Frenchie as for the nuns of the abbey
they seem to be of no help if they're
around it all the visitors from the
Vatican are greeted by the Mother
Superior an inhospitable hooded host
who's basically a modified darth sidious
other than her the place at first it
seems suspiciously empty it turns out
that there's a good reason for that the
God Squad it becomes clear early on that
evil has taken root within the abbey an
impression that's confirmed when Irene
meets some of the Abbey's shell-shocked
nuns it appears that the sisters of the
abbey have spent centuries in constant
prayer to keep a demon from entering the
world to report all in the Abbey but
it's starting to look like a losing
fight as the nuns final act kicks in
Irene is enlisted to help pray the devil
away she's joined by an entire squad of
nuns who mean business
all praying like their lives depend on
it's an awesome moment but also
completely fake as it shortly revealed
that none of those nuns actually exist
stop believing when Burke and Frenchy
reunite with Irene their presence snaps
the sister back to reality she's not
fighting off the demon nun with a group
of other Catholics instead she's having
an incredibly complex vision seeing what
appears to be the last stand of the
abbeys now-dead residence I
Birk realized that they have been alone
inside the abbey the entire time saved
for the demon Valek and his minions it's
revealed to the audience that the two
nuns from the opening scene were
actually the final two nuns in the Abbey
trying to keep phallic from possessing a
human and entering the world beyond st.
carta they realized that the nun they're
investigating didn't die in sin she died
in an act of sacrifice with this truth
revealed it's time for the final
showdown with the big bad nun just got
real
bloody hell after stealing themselves
for the final battle our holy heroes
descend into the catacombs there Irene
realizes the meaning of a vision she's
been having since childhood a message in
those visions Mary points the way turns
out to be a set of instructions that are
literally true as she follows a pointing
Virgin Mary statue to a conspicuous fake
wall using the key from the movies
opening the trio unlocks a hidden door
to a secret passage revealing an ancient
glass relic containing the blood of
Jesus Christ
armed with this powerful weapon the
three go deeper into the catacombs to
confront VALIC and hopefully close off
the abbeys gate to hell
things go south when Irene literally
stumbles onto a trap
she's briefly possessed by valley until
Frenchy breaks the relic and smears the
blood of Christ onto her skin the move
drives the demon away but not without a
fight Irene and Valek tumble into the
water of a flooded room
Valek holds Irene under water until she
goes limp seemingly drowning her and
then Irene spits the entire container of
Christ's blood into balik's face
grossing the demon out so much that it
decides to go back to hell
did I get any in my mouth evil persists
when Christ's blood spills into the
water of the flooded room Ballack is
overwhelmed by its holy might the demon
dissolves and the Rif is sealed up in
the process as well just like that the
evil has been banished the heroes have
apparently won or so it seems the next
day as Frenchy prepares to transport
Burke and Irene back to the village he
rubs a hand across his neck revealing a
conspicuous new sign of the inverted
cross on his skin apparently marking him
as being possessed by something evil
that's right it looks like our hero's
victory isn't so certain after all after
all that the demon accomplished its goal
full circle the movie cuts to 20 years
later revisiting a scene from the very
first conjuring movie it's revealed that
the lecture the Warrens were seen giving
in that movie about a possessed man
named maurice was the same maurice we
know better as Frenchy possessed by
Ballack she saw something during the
encounter Dalek touches Lorraine and
triggers within her the vision of Edie
dying that haunted her all throughout
the conjuring - turns out the visions
the Warrens had of the demon nun in that
movie all came from this encounter with
Maryse meaning their climactic battle
was set into motion before the events of
the first movie had even happened just
like that the movie ties the whole
series together drawing a straight line
from the events of Saint carta to the
warrens final showdown with the demented
demon making the nun and the two
conjuring movies a complete story about
a thirty year struggle between the
forces of good and evil
you
[Applause]